est à Monsieur Erwan balanan pour le
groupe démocrate merci merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
dans le dans le Finistère nous en avons
connu des tempêtes pour tous celle qui
vient de dévaster la pointe de la
Bretagne et le nord-ouest de la France
avait un nom
siarant pour nous habitants de la 8e
circonscription du Finistère il restera
un autre prénom un autre nom et surtout
un visage associé à cette tempête celui
de Frédéric Despo agent d'énédis décédé
en travaillant à rétablir l'électricité
pour des milliers de Bretons il avait 46
ans et 3
enfants originaire de hoch il venait
dans le cadre de la force d'intervention
rapide avec de nombreuses agents enedis
pour réparer le réseau électrique
complètement dévasté je souhaite et vous
l'avez fait aussi en mon nom et au nom
des habitants de ma circonscription lui
rendre hommage ainsi qu'à sa famille son
son sens du devoir pardon nous honore je
veux aussi remercier et surtout
féliciter le préfet du Finistère et ses
services tous les agents publics et tous
les élus des collectivités locales les
forces de l'ordre les pompiers et la
sécurité civile ainsi que les citoyens
qui ont fait preuve d'une solidarité été
incroyable alors si cette crise a été
bien anticipée et bien gérée elle nous
interroge nous savons le dérèglement
climatique ne va ne va qu'accientter ces
catastrophes nous sommes devenus
dépendants aux télécommunications et la
coupure totale de tous les réseaux
mobiles et filair a été particulièrement
mal vécu par tous habitants élus et
forces de l'ordre il est primordial
primordial pardon d'en tirer les leçons
pour améliorer notre anticipation et
protéger la population dans la
continuité du déplacement de Jean-Noël
barauier que je remercie pour son
soutien je souhaite m'adresser à madame
la Première ministre comment l'État
compte-il améliorer son plan de gestion
de crise et d'adaptation pour améliorer
la résilience des réseaux et leur
capacité à rester opérationnel